[Music]
hey
my name is rhonda glover reese rhonda
served in the fbi for over 34 years
she's now a law enforcement consultant
and certified career coach
today i'll be breaking down clips from
movies
and television about surveillance
blowing cover
donnie brasco jesus joe that's holmen
u.s attorney coming at us
the guy on the right don't be stopped
remember me southern district
and watching that clip it just took me
back
when i was working as an undercover
agent
joe trained me he's a legend in the
bureau as an undercover
hey what are you doing the key thing is
to understand
is that when an undercover agent is
in a role they have to continue in that
role as much as possible
what he did in the film hitting
that assistant united states attorney
that was fine
he's building a case and he was able to
maintain his role without giving up his
cover
don't call me joe and i'll cut you
through you understand if that
undercover agent
is in another role and he has another
name then
you call them by that name so what
happened
in that clip it was completely
appropriate forget about
it following the family the sopranos
unit one this is control baby bing
headed your way
unit five do you have visual contact of
princess bing
control they are
going into the house so they want to
make sure everybody's out the house they
want to know where everybody is
units weren't approximately one minute
you'll have them made great jetta sc
team the location read secure you have
one hour and thirty minutes
it is incredibly important for the
agent that was in the van baby bang
ahead of your way
that agent had the eye that agent had
the responsibility
to really monitor who's coming in and
out it was important for him to stay
focused you want to have all the tools
that you need to have
in your car you need to you got bottom
thing out of your way
excuse me you want to have your food you
want to have your snacks
you want to have everything charged up
your radio charged up you want your
phone charger you want to have your
surveillance kit
that's what i like to call it you know
you want to have your go bag
in the event that you're going to be
sitting for a long long time
patrol we are working on entry estimate
three or four minutes
i've been on kidnapping investigations
where the surveillance is like 24 hours
erio junta cadillac dts returning
when passed me up the street about five
minutes ago so when you're doing a
surveillance you take surveillance
notes and you have a log so in that log
you want to indicate
who left where they're leaving from
and the time that they're leaving all
the information that you need to
give you a clear picture of the
movement of whoever you are surveilling
we're finished for today here ladies and
gentlemen
cover story miss congeniality
hey hey hey hey oh
jesus christ ah sorry i uh
i i had a bite of my bagel and i forgot
to pray sandra bullock in her character
she was
incredibly quick on her feet to
come up with that quick prayer no it's
not working
it's not working five minutes
the listening devices and the earpieces
and all of those
things should be checked and double
checked before
actually using them oh
dear jesus throughout the film they've
looked at her
as being a little different so by doing
something like that
that was just totally in character she
thinks i'm funny and i applaud her
for thinking so quickly on her feet
please forgive me for not praying before
i had a bite of my bagel and shmear
well it worked it it
it worked for everybody in the room
thank you very much
amen front and follow the wire
i'm gonna play that spy game do you
remember the spy game yeah who was it
a tall black guy over there i'm the
front yard of the follow front and
follow is just
a surveillance technique you'll have
someone in front
of the subject that you're surveilling
and you'll have someone in the back
they're really spot-on but uh one thing
that i really picked up on
the older brother
he got a little bit close to someone
seeing him
write down the license plate number sean
when you're doing a surveillance you
must be very very discreet
because you don't want people to see who
you're following
and you don't want anyone to see that
you're writing down tags
now you probably should not use your
kids
to do police work but they did an okay
job
my flesh and blood backstory imperium
i was in the marines for three years on
a wmd squad in iraq
and i'm starting to wonder
no in this clip daniel radcliffe
is preparing to infiltrate a white
supremacist group
i was in the marines for three years on
a wmd squad in iraq
but i saw a lot of things over there
that changed me he's on his way to being
a very very good undercover
he was coached before he went in
he's got a new identity he's got a new
place to live
you're going to be next to the subjects
and the targets of that investigation
you're going to be right in the thick of
things and so
you want to have as much information as
possible
and if that means doing an incredible
amount
of research then you need to do that so
you can be prepared
so you you don't get tripped up
the key thing is that he has to be
mindful of who he is on the inside
and remember that he is playing a role
and not to get too deep into that role
that he loses himself
and that's why it's important that the
the handlers the agents that are going
to be
working with him that they watch over
him to make sure that he's okay
i'm only so hard on you because i'm
trying to protect you recording device
the informant we need some specific
numbers
well what would you be willing to accept
isn't that really the question
that adm has already eaten all the girls
in this
clip matt damon's character is really
messing with the recording device
we could be growing 20 000 tons i'm
going in
we got to shut this down wait hold on i
need your help i think he's got it
in real life he would not have access to
it
all he or she needs to know is that
they're going to carry this
in and this is going to be with them
they don't need to know how it works
they don't need to be touching it they
don't need to be doing anything with it
at all they're not going to be able to
take apart
a briefcase and touch the device because
they're tampering with it
no mark no
no you want to be able to say in a court
of law
that that source didn't have anything to
do
with the recording apparatus jerry's
gonna
love that you don't want to even have to
address
that question this can all be used
against you in the court of law
educating rookies in too deep you didn't
kill the black man you got started your
stripes baby make me cry
no problems show me with a kid omar
epson his character
serving as an undercover officer acting
in that undercover capacity he did a
great job because he knew that he was
being tested
what they really want you to prove is
that you're not a cop you know he's a
police officer so
he knew he had to come up with a way
that he could show them
he would do whatever he needed to do
to demonstrate to the guys that he was
part of them
he must know how to shoot very very well
because
he ensured that he was firing that
weapon
very very badly
intentionally counting his rounds and
they're just like man you can't
shoot you can't shoot worth nothing yo i
had the kid right there man
but my boy got crazy hard he's crazy he
can't shoot
we can't ask him to shoot because he's
not going to get it done
agents and officers when they are acting
in an undercover capacity there may come
a time where they
may have to break the law but they're
going to have to have permission
in order to do that your life depends on
split-second decisions that was a really
good
scene for him to demonstrate that you
could still be
part of the group in an undercover
capacity
and not get anyone hurt is that place
cool enough for you to understand
shaking the tail casino you see if a
phone's tapped the feds can only listen
in on the stuff involving crimes
so on routine calls they have to click
off after a few minutes
robert de niro's character was talking
about minimization
you have to be very very careful and
very very intentional when you're doing
a wiretap
yeah give me a treat anytime anyone's on
that phone
and they're talking about anything
outside of the criminal activity
that's taking place you are supposed to
turn that recording off i'm going to do
some shopping afterwards you want to go
and so they wait a few minutes and then
they turn the recording back on
you're checking in on that conversation
to make sure they continue
to talk about things that are
non-pertinent
okay he's out into the ground unit
and looking at that scene with the the
the agent was
in the window and he had this huge
massive radio i'm just grateful that i
didn't have to deal with
a huge radio like that during
surveillance
nicki couldn't even go for a ride
without changing cars at least six times
before he could shake all his tails
and because of all the planes he had to
use underground garages
joe pesci's character is really trying
to shake the fbi he knows that he's
being followed
the fbi knows that he's incredibly
surveillance conscious so they're going
to be mindful of that
one thing that joe pesci's character
can't he cannot do
is change his face
he's driving all these cars he's
switching all these cars
but it's still him in these cars
[Music]
so while joe pesci is doing his best
to evade surveillance the fbi
is doing their due diligence
[Music]
first contact black klansman
yeah who's this ron stallworth here this
is walter
returning your call from the
organization
the organization well your first contact
you definitely want to use a phone
that is not connected to the law
enforcement agency that you work for
that's one thing that's your
real name right is it is it ron
stallworth right
secondly you do not want to use your
real name
you don't want to use anything that's
going to tie you back to
law enforcement i'm interested in
receiving some reading materials from
you
it was very very clear that he was just
taking a chance
he didn't think anybody would call him
back what's your story
so now he's gonna have to remember
everything that he said
because it very well can actually come
back
sometime during the investigation well
since you asked
my sister pamela she was just recently
accosted the point here
is that you have to be ready you got to
get ready to be ready because you never
know when they're going to call
well good luck ron with your new redneck
friend raid
gone wrong point break
scooby come on scooby here scooby
scooby oh yo what
this was no uh you would no
have you seen my dog i got a little dog
i'm missing it's a cockapoo like that
he's gotta think about your dog
he's just not convincing if you're going
to have someone
show up and take on that type of role
you don't want them
to be like gary busey well is there
anybody else around you
they're going to be very very humble
about
looking for their dog okay here's how it
is babbitt now breads are going to go in
the back door
cullen's going to back me up i want you
at the side window by the hedge
having a raid in the middle of the day
is not the optimum time
to conduct a raid
people are up people are moving around
you're going to make sure
that the gentleman that is mowing the
lawn that he
is secure and he is out of the way
is not enough to address these subjects
in that house then you have
keanu reeves he doesn't even have a ray
jacket on what a flake
you need everyone fully identified
as fbi agents
heavy firepower to back your team up
the best way possible get a real cowboys
right batman and robin
wanting out the departed i'm going nuts
man i can't be someone else every
day it's been a year of this i've had
enough of this what happens when an
undercover
officer or agent has demonstrated
that they've had just too much and they
want to get out
then you have to be responsible
as a law enforcement officer to get them
out
i'm down all right most of the people in
the world do it every day mark
wahlberg's character
was not helpful one bit now we're the
only two people on the face of this
earth that even though you're a cop
how about we just erase your file he's
saying that they're in charge
they're in charge of his life that's not
going to make any undercover feel good
when you have somebody
that's not supportive that was your joke
as an undercover
you could possibly start having all
kinds of feelings and your intuition may
kick in i'm gonna take costello huh
i mean what's wrong with taking him on
any one of the million felonies
that you've seen him do
or i've seen him do but the bottom line
is that you have to have the evidence
you have to have the information
that supports what you're feeling we are
building a case and it takes time you
know that
something's wrong i'm telling you
something's wrong
something is not right and he can't put
his finger on it that
is a clue for the other
officers to to really support him
and start asking those questions and
start figuring it out
yeah maybe counter-surveillance killing
eve
when looking at her skills she was on
point
she slows down so he could catch up she
knew
that he was following her and so she
drew him
in sometimes you get tunnel vision and
you're not aware of your surroundings
and you're not
mindful of who could be following you
or what that person actually can be
doing
[Music]
he had no business going into that club
it was just so populated so many people
just dancing around
and having a good time and then it's
loud is that a
good place to be
the key thing is that you know the
person that you're following you have
some idea of who they are
what they're capable of
[Applause]
and she was the victor at the end
recording a conversation
the conversation what do you think
i always think that he was once
somebody's baby boy
we're his mother as father all his
uncles now
anyway surveillance fans they're not
just a hollywood thing
they are still being used to conduct
surveillances
gene hackman's character he was he was
overdressed he could at least put on a
jumpsuit that has the business
identified on the jumpsuit
you know you have to think about those
things who's watching you when you're
watching
do you want to blend in as much as
possible you don't want to stand
out and he stood out about the second
position
it's not so good it is a possibility for
you to hear a conversation
from that far away
they had all these different vantage
points and they had
different people in different places
they're going to put all that together
so you can hear what's what we heard
or did we here informant law and order
svu hypnosis doesn't make people do
something they don't already want to do
so if she kissed you she wanted to
sounds like he's rationalizing the
officers of the svu
are using this informant to garner
information from this target did you
teach trust how to hypnotize people
i taught him everything i know huh well
you're willing to help us now the reason
why
law enforcement would get someone that's
close to that subject
and ask them to help because that target
knows them very very well and they're
going to drop their guard and they're
going to be able to share
information come on declan are you
saying that you've used hypnosis to have
sex
it's not a big deal but the key thing is
the person
that law enforcement has asked to
step up it's do they know how to do it
when's the last time you did this
[Music]
and so like towards the end of that
conversation he gave that guy a sada
he's looking at him like are you
recording me
you have to be very very clear to them
about
how they should do it the kind of things
they should say the things that they
should not say
in order to have a conversation with
a target look deep into my eyes you're
under arrest
planning the heat
well senator bullock is playing a fbi
agent
it appears that she is the team leader
on the
execution of this arrest and search
she's just out of line she's not on the
swat team
so she's not going to be close to swat
allow
the the swap team to do what the swat
team is there to do
and get out of their way the place is
clean ashburn looks like your
theory has a few holes in it let's roll
boys what's interesting
about sandra bullock's character is that
she is
clearly someone that nobody wants to
work with do you think it's clean huh
oh here we go i know that as an agent a
former agent
i would not have wanted to work with her
you know they loved these houses during
the prohibition era
people loved to drink it even though
they weren't supposed to and these
houses had all these little nooks and
crannies where they could hide it
like this one she could have easily said
you know you want to look
at this locate you want to look here she
had that information before she got
there
that that's a possibility and so she
could have shared that
maybe these guys are are right for a
change
stranger things have happened right guys
she knows what she's doing but she's
full of herself and she's not a team
player
you don't want to be that agent where
people don't want to work with you
let's go
conclusion you can tell when they have
someone
on staff or that's part of the team
that they've got a law enforcement
background that they're able to share
what you can do and what what is real
and what is not and what's going to fly
and what's going to make sense